hello there reject nation umbrella I'm
John Humphrey Dark Phoenix has a final
trailer that's out right out weird time
to release this offer
[Music]
[Applause]
the kids are calling you Phoenix
whenever you eat cheesy
quicksilver's debt see ya
yeah that crawler has some white teeth
[Applause]
see the thing is like nobody seems to
have any faith in this movie but I think
it cuts cool trailers cuts great
trailers hey guys before we start
talking a little bit more about this I
want to say thank you to everyone who's
been fond of our patreon page over there
we do weekly Q&A s as well as TV show
reaction stream along for many shows
that includes attack on Titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood one punch man as well as
reaction highlights included that
includes
one punch man my hero academia Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood and
supernatural which we also offer stream
along for and John did all the episodes
just finished for hunting and Hell house
and I did Gotham I went in a really
weird order there let's talk about this
it's pretty obvious Quicksilver does I
mean they made it very clear in the last
trailer that mystique dies and the whole
funeral settings about her I guess this
doesn't render like at that point but
let's not just confirm this they have
that one line with Quicksilver needed
that they go to space now cool and then
they have that one shot that you seen
the other trailer is running up the
debris headed towards Jean yeah Faison
any of the other rest of the trailers I
was gonna say the rest of the trailer I
mean yeah yeah and I mean they used him
sparingly in the last movie right but
but in Apocalypse it ends that he's part
of the team and clearly he's part of the
team now unless they do some weird thing
where he's like I don't want to be here
anymore all the way yeah mom's like you
need to come back home and keep living
with me unless they're trying to like
really MCU this up by completely hiding
that fact yeah I mean I like the intro
with them like trying to save the
astronauts and stuff like that I mean I
don't know it kind of made it look like
they were doing x-men things as well as
having the whole Dark Phoenix scenario I
missed that I guess because you know
with the apocalypse and the crest into
making the action like huge and giant I
feel like they didn't kind of lose some
of the
more down-to-earth charm and even though
this looks like a big you know
spectacular installment I didn't like
having something like that to chew on in
this trailer yeah I suppose I'm worried
about this phone I'm very worried like
the first two trailers I really did love
a lot it seems like you know the
generally when I write here about early
test screenings people tend to not like
whatever that's always what I rarely
hear about the of course there are those
cases where you do hear like really
positive response to the test screening
but I know the dark phoenix film has not
been having the best of test screenings
lately and a lot of reshoots and whatnot
but at the same time yeah I wasn't a big
fan of Apocalypse sophie turner I think
is I I mean I don't know or work outside
of Game of Thrones which I think she's
does a wonderful job and yeah and she's
she's really grown over time on that
show like I've really come to enjoy her
the older she's gotten and the one thing
is as much as I didn't care for her in
Apocalypse at least the glimpses in this
trailer I feel like I might like her a
little more in this but I'm very much on
a maybe their breath because it's a
trailer and I'm sure that they can find
the best moments and stuff well there
just seems to be some like really corny
cheesy dialogue yeah yeah this was my
least favorite I thought the other two
trailers were much better I don't know
if it's the idea that said that the time
gap between the last trailer and then
this one where my feelings have just
become a little bit more I don't know
about this one because the last trailer
I was like this I think this might be
great I'm gonna be I'm gonna play that
card but now lately I'm like I just
don't know I just have no idea now I
don't know why the vibe I get is just
yet these are probably pretty good
trailers masking something that is
ultimately very messy or just not
ultimately going to be satisfying but
that's just a weird instinct I guess you
know no I don't think it's all the word
you hear is everybody's worried and
nobody's
I also think it's just strange timing to
release this trailer that's fine the
final trailer because this movie has a
few weeks before it comes to how it
likes several weeks and it just does
gonna get buried an endgame right now
yeah I don't know what the idea what the
marketing is is if you like oh you
released this trailer or in terms of
writing some Marvel hype or you know the
fact that we know that had 20th Century
Fox and Disney are merging but I'm like
but I don't know if then I feel like
this is just gonna get overshadowed and
you or you'll forget about this one I
think they should have released this
final trailer like two to three weeks
after M king or something not a week
before and game comes out your final
trailer yeah oh yeah I just don't feel
like that's a way to ride a highboy if I
feel like that's a way to get your hype
wave just overpowered by a totally
different yeah and I cuz I think like
you could probably do an intense
breakdown video like solely from new
rock stars or something like that where
or mr. Sunday movies who would really
break this trailer down you could
probably feel like you got a lot of new
things from it to get you excited for it
but unless they're not one of those
people who does those intense breakdowns
or watches those intense breakdowns this
trailer generally felt the same you know
like yeah they're going to NASA I mean
they're helping out NASA just kind of
makes me scratch my head and go
I thought everyone hates mutants you
know especially in the 90s at this point
you know so this is kind of a weird like
other than raising that minor question
we're just gonna play an Act one is
forward thinking people truths you know
they're taller that is true but that's
about the only real new piece I could
gather other than I'm sure if I really
slowed this down like a ho I saw a
couple of new things gonna help I don't
know I mean I like some of the imagery I
think the effects actually look pretty
good but yeah I don't know ultimately
like it looks like it has all the things
that you would want out of the trailer
but no it's the same thing I said before
there's just something I don't know
exactly what to call it but there's
something inside that doesn't fully
convinced me no see I kind of get an
impression that it's a little over
convoluted oh yeah well I mean and I
guess there's also the element that we
know that they're going to try and cram
a very prominent and a very important
story line for the x-men into this last
movie that falls into a weird place in
the x-men franchise in general because
it's it's the end its list we're passing
the guard over to Disney now and this
movie is in a weird position of being
this like I don't know afterthought or
like we were already making this deals
so like I don't know it feels almost
like such a consequential story for such
an inconsequential movie like it's one
of those things where I'm gonna watch it
because it's x-men yeah at the same time
I'm like I don't really know who or what
to specifically look forward to yeah
yeah there's not a character here where
I'm like I'm super excited and arguing
that should be it's weird because the
first two trailers I did have that [ __ ]
but then in between time of just
thinking about this movie and then
landing here I don't know anyway what do
you guys think are you excited for this
do you think they should have waited
release this trailer comment below I
want to give a patient a shot to a man
named JT JT you messaged me on Twitter
you've been one of our longtime friends
patronage X and I'm letting you know
right now that my social media is
currently inactive until after I watch
endgame so if you're messaging me there
you don't want to do that he did bring
up a good point about this trailer
called Anna Luke based on Z movie he's
wondering why more people aren't
covering it I don't know man
I don't know that I did a reaction for
it on the Stardust app and I'll tell you
guys that trailer is a badass trailer
and JT if there are people who made it
to the end this video I'm hoping more
people go and watch that Ana trailer
because I know
you really want more people to watch it
it looks really cool then one day you'll
land yourself a hottie like that Anna in
that trailer
yeah and then she can beat the crap out
of you but you like it because you
probably you are you freak Japanese free
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell check us out on
patreon we'll catch you guys later